>> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU,
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," TONIGHT IF
YOU VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP, YOU
ARE A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY AND
WILL BE DEALT WITH AS SUCH.
ARE YOU OR HAVE YOU EVER BEEN A
SUPPORTER OF DONALD TRUMP?
IS THIS JOE BIDEN'S UNITY THAT
HE TALKED ABOUT WHEN HE WAS
INAUGURATED OR IS THIS ABOUT THE
SOUL OF THE NATION THAT HE IS
GOING TO ADDRESS TOMORROW.
COMING UP, WE WILL PLAY OUR
CHILLING REMARKS AND PREVIEW THE
BIG SPEECH IN INDEPENDENCE HALL
WHERE PRESIDENT UNITY IS
PLANNING A CALL TO ACTION
AGAINST AMERICANS HE IS CALLING
SEMI FASCISTS.
PLUS THE GOLDEN STATE HAS A NEW
REGULATION WITH GAS POWERED
CARS, BUT THE VERY SAME STATE IS
NOW BEGGING ITS RESIDENTS, DON'T
CHARGE YOUR ELECTRIC VEHICLES,
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRIC
GRID IS ABOUT TO CRASH.
WE HAVE THAT REPORT
STRAIGHT-AHEAD, SO MUCH FOR
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
ALSO THE BOMBSHELL
WHISTLE-BLOWER ALLEGATIONS FROM
INSIDE THE FBI.
AGENTS ARE SOUNDING THE ALARM ON
THE RAMPANT POLITICAL BIAS
INTERRUPTING WHAT SHOULD BE
AMERICA AND THE WORLD'S PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, BUT WE
BEGAN WITH THE VERY LATEST
ANTI-TRUMP SPEAR TACTICS
SURROUNDING THE RAID AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
DESPERATE TO STOP A FEDERAL
JUDGE FROM APPOINTING THE MASTER
TO REVIEW THE CASE.
AND DOJ INDICATED THAT AMERICAN
SHOULD JUST SIMPLY TRUST THEIR
JUDGMENT.
ALSO TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHAVE PUBLIC OPINION WITH THAT
IMAGE RIGHT THERE SHOWING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS STREWN
ACROSS THE FLOOR, NEXT TO A BOX
OF FRAME "TIME" MAGAZINE COVERS
AND A SUBSEQUENT REBUTTAL.
AND HAS STATED "THE GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSE GRATUITOUSLY INCLUDED A
PHOTOGRAPH OF ALLEGEDLY
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS FROM THE
CONTAINER FOR DRAMATIC EFFECT."
AND ON THE SOCIAL RESPONSE,
TERRIBLE THE WAY THAT THE FBI
DURING THE RATE OF MAR-A-LAGO
THROUGH DOCUMENTS HAPHAZARDLY
ALL OVER THE FLOOR.
PERHAPS PRETENDING IT WAS ME
THAT DID THAT.
AND THEN STARTED TAKING PICTURES
OR THE PUBLIC TO SEE.
THOUGHT THEY WANTED THEM KEPT
SECRETS, LUCKY I DECLASSIFIED.
MEANWHILE LEGAL SCHOLAR JONATHAN
TURLEY WHO WILL JOIN US IN A
MOMENT TWEETED THIS PHOTO COULD
LEAD AND OBVIOUSLY MISLEADING
IMPRESSION THAT DOCUMENTS WERE
ALL OVER THE FLOOR WHEN THIS
APPEARS TO BE THE WORK OF FBI
AGENTS.
AND JONATHAN TURLEY CONTINUED
FOR CRITICS THE PHOTO MAY APPEAR
TO BE ANOTHER EFFORT WITH PRIOR
LEAKS TO HELP GAIN THE OPTICS
AND DISCUSSION WHERE CLEARLY A
VISUAL AID OF DOCUMENTS WITH
COVERS.
AND WAS INTENDED FOR PUBLIC
CONSUMPTION.
KEEP IN MIND BEING HANDLED BY
THE SAME WASHINGTON OFFICE THAT
GAVE HILLARY CLINTON A FREE PASS
AFTER SHE MISHANDLED TOP-SECRET
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL ON HER
UNSECURED PRIVATE SERVERS.
AND ATTEMPTED TO DESTROY THE
EVIDENCE, 33,000 EMAILS, BLEACH
BAIT, ET CETERA.
ALSO THE SAME FBI OFFICE THAT
BROUGHT US OPERATION CROSSFIRE
HURRICANE, THE DIRTY DOSSIER,
FISA FRAUD, FREQUENTLY
PETER STRZOK, LISA PAGE,
ANDREW WEISSMANN.
AND THE SAME OFFICE FOR
TIM TEBOW "SUDDENLY RETIRED" WAS
REPORTEDLY ESCORTED OUT OF THE
BOROUGH AFTER ALLEGATIONS OF
LIBERAL BIAS AND MISCONDUCT IN
THE HUNTER BIDEN INVESTIGATION
AND ACCUSED OF SLOW WALKING THE
PROBE INTO HUNTER'S LAPTOP FROM
HELL TO SECURE THE ELECTION PER
JOE BIDEN, PEOPLE THAT RETIRE
FROM THE FBI ARE NOT WALKED OUT
OF THE HEADQUARTERS BUILDING ON
A HOT SUNNY AFTERNOON IN AUGUST
AFTER BEING SCREAMED AT AND
RIDICULED BY HIS BOSSES LIKE A
LAPTOP.
THIS WAS A FIRING FROM.
BUT NO ASKING US TO SIMPLY TRUST
THIS VERY SAME OFFICE IN THE
WASHINGTON SEWER AND SWAMP WITH
AN INVESTIGATION INTO
JOE BIDEN'S CHIEF POLITICAL
RIVAL.
THEY WANT ABSOLUTELY NO SCRUTINY
T AT ALL WHATSOEVER.
AND THEY RATED MAR-A-LAGO AND
WOULD NOT LET TERMS ATTORNEYS
OBSERVED THE SEARCH AND DEMANDED
THAT MAR-A-LAGO TURN OFF ALL
SECURITY CAMERAS SO THAT THEY
COULD CONDUCT IN PRIVATE.
I THOUGHT WE WANTED -- CAMS AND
CAMERAS ON POLICE FOR A GOOD
REASON.
IT KEEPS EVERYBODY HONEST.
THEY DID NOT WANT THE AFFIDAVIT
RELEASE AND THE HEAVILY REDACTED
THE AFFIDAVIT AFTER THE JUDGE
ORDERED THE RELEASE.
EVEN REDACTED THE REASONS FOR
THE REDUCTIONS AND NOW THEY
DON'T WANT A SPECIAL MASTER TO
REVIEW THE CASE.
SO WHAT EXACTLY ARE THEY HIDING?
AND WHY WOULD DONALD TRUMP OR
ANYONE ELSE TRUST BIDE